mr. Dyle no there never laughs
but even here in this rich state there is
rubble for years farmers have been struggling
with places too low it's been hard for them to
make both ends meet to clothe and educate the
children to pay taxes to meet the note at
the bank here and everywhere so many don't
own their home though the land either almost 50
percent are now Kenneth living in other men's
houses working other man's land bosses were
working all over the country nothing along
at all and there are large living group eat
for the day the feeders gasoline or a machine
and now this machine is coming The Chronicle
you don't see many people in these
fields anymore even at harvest on
beach wheat fields farther west
you don't see many people after
thousands and thousands of them only a few
years ago harvested wheat thousands more
harvested corn and here they are
some of them crumb of the machine
a lame man who had walked in for miles on
crutches said to us I don't know what some
of us would do if it weren't for
the food the government gives us